for both of you to start here because
the book and now the movie is is largely
about shedding light on things about
growing up that can be scary or feel too
embarrassing to ask about so I kind of
wanted to turn that idea towards
filmmaking what is a seemingly silly
question about what it takes to make a
movie that you were afraid to ask when
you were first starting out that you
would now encourage newer actors to
speak up and ask about oh
oh God I gotta think about that
um I I've been doing this for a while
um and I have two acting parents so I I
never really felt awkward about asking
anything but
um I don't know I still have moments
where I'm like oh I don't want to ask
this because it's going to seem really
embarrassing that I don't know this
already
um but I I've always felt really uh open
and able to talk about things on set and
I think that's a testament to all of the
people and all of the crew and all of
the directors that I've worked with who
have really made the set a wonderful
safe place to learn and to grow as an
actor so I'm I'm really thankful for
that
makes me very happy to hear that yeah I
I just realized I've been standing on my
marks wrong for 20 years or so
um I thought your toes were supposed to
go on the tape and they're supposed to
go right where the tape ends
a small thing but actually sometimes
you know ask how you really stand on a
mark no no question is too small I've
heard the mark thing quite a bit as an
answer you have oh my gosh that makes me
feel so much better thank you it's
always the market eye lines yes yeah eye
lines little tape things now I think
yeah yeah yeah that's super helpful it
is yeah very helpful yeah Rachel I
wanted to ask you a little something
about working with Abby so even with all
your experience is there anything you
saw Abby do on the set of this film that
made you think like wow I had with I
wish I had the courage to try that when
I was first starting out at the
beginning of my career oh my God
sorry Abby close your ears
um just what you said courage she has so
much courage
um and curiosity uh endless curiosity
and I I just think you know it just
makes you such a special actor but yeah
I mean I just remember being off stage
watching her try on the maxi pad with
the her pantyhose and just thinking she
did every tick differently you just
leaned right into it you had you were
not embarrassed at all you're like I
mean that's a testament to what an old
soul you are that you know you're like
this is no big deal this is my job and
I'm gonna wear this pad like nobody's
ever worn a pad before
um but yes courage you have it in spades
in life too yeah thank you that's the
that's the type of course a movie and a
story like this needs you make a big
impression by attacking everything with
such courage like that it's gonna
influence I bet a lot of other people
well beyond what the book already has
speaking of that idea so of course this
uh this book and ultimately the movie is
going to wind up being a pretty uh
pivotal thing in people's lives in terms
of you know feeling like like they're
seen and like certain things aren't
scary about growing up but I wanted to
take that idea and turn it towards you
in terms of a movie that you had when
you were growing up that you know made
made you feel like you had guidance via
film hmm oh that's a great question
I
I I so I did grow up with like a ton of
films and all of that I I don't know if
there was a specific movie that I really
really felt connected to but I did love
The Studio Ghibli movies as a kid I love
all of those I still I want to do like a
binge watch of all of them with my
friends that would be so fun oh my gosh
they're amazing okay yeah okay I love
Tiki's delivery service I loved Ponyo
um all of those Princess Mononoke is my
current favorite
um yeah no okay okay
um yeah but I always loved those and I
loved seeing strong female characters
and I I saw myself reflected in them
most of the time and I really loved
watching those films was that Spirited
Away oh okay yeah okay I've seen one I
think all of all of those movies right
all are amazing yes yes
that's awesome thanks have it for you
Rachel ah I'm a huge Anna Green Gables
fan and
um because you know what you're asking
about I it made me feel like it's okay
to be an original it's okay to walk to
the beat of your own drum you know she
was unabashedly herself
and um I think when you're growing up
just to see that that goes okay for
someone you know and it in fact it's a
better way to be inside of yourself and
um it just gave me courage to to be
myself excellent uh selections right
there and you made a movie that I think
is going to give a lot of people out
there courage to be themselves as well
so thank you for the movie thank you for
your time today oh thank you so much
thank you